the actual world that Rupert and the VFX
team is created for the audience is like
something I think nobody's ever seen
before it's mint and I'm accessories
such an immersive experience we shot
with a with an imax frame ratio you
really get the full experience of imac
and also that the 65 mil helps very well
because it has a very narrow depth of
field so you really feel some space and
when we translated it 3d you can really
play with that I can't really imagine
that the experience of having that you
know on a screen that sort of like is
all-encompassing would be pretty
dramatic you are the first of your kind
but you're not invulnerable maybe next
time you can design me better you're
really and we built the world
practically you know it's very little
full visual effects working so I think
you really become so much more immersed
just in the real textures of the world
you know the Geisha walking down the
hallway that's all reals notice effect
in that so to see that 3d on 65 mil you
really are present you almost watch the
film as a ghost you know you move
through the world and you really feel
like you're immersed I was so invested
in my own tasket handing of this task of
creating this multi-dimensional
character that I didn't really know how
stunning the world that was being
creative created around me was going to
actually look it's really a experience
in itself just taking in the visuals of
the film not even the performances the
action sequences those are like
obviously like in the foreground but
everything else is going on is so
spectacular imax 3d is it's definitely
the best way to watch the soon they
created me
but they cannot control me
you
you